- [Voiceover] Let's talk
about buffer capacity.
Buffer capacity is a property of a buffer
and it tells you how much
acid or base you can add
before the pH starts changing.
Basically, as
your buffer capacity goes up,
which I'm going to abbreviate BC,
as your buffer capacity goes up,
you can
add
more of your acid or base
before the pH starts changing a lot.
That might seem like a pretty vague
and qualitative definition,
so let's go through an example
to see what that might look like exactly.
The example we're gonna look at
is going to be using
an acetic acid buffer.
So acetic acid is CH three COOH.
And we're gonna abbreviate
that in this talk using HA.
And this is an aqueous solution
and that is reversibly reacting
to form H plus ion
and CH three COO minus,
or acetate.
And so we're gonna abbreviate
acetate in this talk
as A minus.
So more information about
this particular buffer.
Acetic acid, the Ka is equal to
1.8 times 10 to the minus five.
And if we take the negative log of that,
that will give us the pKa,
which is also useful.
And the pKa of acetic acid is 4.74.
So that'll tell us a lot about
the behavior of this buffer.
And the last thing we need to know for
predicting the behavior of our buffer
is what the ratio is
between our HA and A minus.
So we're going to be
looking at a buffer where
A minus over HA, this ratio,
is equal to 1.82.
Based on this ration,
we can calculate the pH.
So the initial pH of our buffer
before we do anything to it,
before we add any acid or we add any base,
the initial pH of our
buffer we can calculate
using the Henderson–Hasselbalch equation.
And so that equation tells
that pH is equal to pKa
plus log of A minus concentration,
or acetate, over acetic
acid concentration.
And if you're not 100% confident
with using this equation,
or you want to know where it comes from,
we actually have separate videos on it,
so I would recommend checking those out.
In this video, we're just going
to use this equation as is.
So if we plug in our values here,
we get that the initial pKa is equal to
4.74, our pKa,
plus log of 1.82,
which is our ratio of A minus over HA.
So then we know our initial pH is equal to
5.00.
What we're gonna do next
is we're gonna look at
two different buffers,
and both of them are going
to be made with acetic acid
and with acetate.
And we're gonna call them
buffer one and buffer two.
So buffer one has a ratio
of A minus NHA that is 1.82.
So the pH is going to be five.
And the A minus concentration,
before we do anything to it,
before we add anything,
is 0.90 molar.
And the HA concentration
is going to be 0.49 molar.
And our second buffer that
we're gonna compare it to
we will call buffer two.
And buffer two also has the
same ratio of acid to base,
except this time both concentrations
are gonna be 10 times
smaller than buffer one.
So our A minus concentration
is 0.090 molar.
And our acetic acid
concentration is 0.049 molar.
And what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna see
what happens to the pH of both of these,
So they both start out with a pH of five,
but how much do they change when we add...
We're going to
add 0.04 moles
of a strong base, sodium hydroxide,
to one liter buffer.
So when you do that,
well it's a buffer.
We know that it's going
to resist the pH change,
but what exactly is happening?
What's the reaction that
goes on when you add this in?
So when you add your strong base,
which is going to
dissociate to form OH minus,
it's going to react with
the acid in your buffer.
So our acid is
CH three COOH.
And we always assume that a strong base
is going to react irreversibly.
So one-sided arrow with a weak acid.
So what happens is this proton
is going to react with OH
minus and we're gonna get
H two O, or water.
And we're gonna make CH three COO minus.
So that's our base.
And so we can see that the hydroxide
is going to react one to
one with our weak acid
and it's gonna produce one
equivalent of our base.
So now we can use this information
to calculate what happens to our buffer
when we add .04 moles of sodium hydroxide.
What's gonna happen is it's gonna react
with our acid.
Which means the concentration
of the acetic acid
is gonna go down by .04 molar.
Our new concentration after it's reacted
is gonna be 0.45 molar.
Sorry, I tried to do that in my head.
And what happens to our
concentration of the base?
Remember that when the acid
reacts with sodium hydroxide
we actually make more base,
So we have to adjust the
concentration of A minus upward.
It actually makes .04 molar acetate
when this reaction happens.
So our new concentration
of our acetate ion
is 0.94 molar.
So these are our final concentrations.
We can no plug them back in to the
Henderson–Hasselbalch
equation to get the pH.
So the pH of buffer one,
I'll put a little subscript one,
is going to be 4.74, the pKa,
plus log of 0.94 molar
divided by 0.45 molar.
And if we plug that into our calculator,
we get that the pH after
we add that hydroxide
is 5.06.
So it's a little bit higher.
It went up by .06.
That makes sense.
We do imagine it would be higher.
If you add base, it becomes more basic
and the pH should go up.
But it didn't change a whole lot,
because it's a buffer.
Now let's compare that with
what happens to buffer two.
We add .04 mole sodium
hydroxide to buffer two.
Our acetic acid concentration
is gonna go down by .04 molar.
So our new concentration
of HA is .009 molar.
By the same reaction,
our base concentration
is gonna go up,
since when the acid reacts,
it makes more conjugate base.
So we're gonna have to add 0.04 molar
to A minus concentration.
And so the new concentration
is going to be 0.13 molar.
And we can plug those concentrations into
the Henderson–Hasselbalch equation
and we get that pH of our buffer two
is equal to 4.74, our pKa,
plus log of 0.13 molar
divided by
0.009 molar.
And so that would be, if we
plugged this into our calculator
this is equal to 1.16.
So if we add that together with our pKa,
we get that the new pH is 5.90 molar.
So the pH changed a whole lot more
for buffer two than for buffer one.
The pH went up by .9 instead of by .06.
So if we were comparing
the buffer capacities
of both of these buffers,
we would say that
buffer one,
well, the buffer changes less when you add
the same amount of acid or base.
So buffer one has the
higher buffer capacity.
Since you don't want these concentrations,
A minus and HA, to be too low,
the general rule of thumb is that you want
your concentrations of HA
and A minus between
0.10 molar and
1.0 molar.
And by following that rule of thumb,
you can make a buffer
where you don't have to worry too much
about adding too much acid or base
before you pH changes,
since that's usually why
you're making a buffer
in the first place.